My name is Ginny Foos, and I'm honored to be here. And it actually brings back
some really great memories. When I was ten,
I was on a television show outside of WGBH
in Boston, which is where I grew up. And I was one of five panelists that
had disabilities. And we, filmed for two years.
And it was a real coming of age experience
for me because, we were asked to sit on very hot
seats, talking about how do you feel about being different, how
do you feel about being teased. And not only was I
saving in psychological cost, I didn't have to see a shrink.
>> I was actually being paid for talking about my feelings. And
I really bonded with the other four individuals. And it was really neat.
unfortunately, we did not stay on air for
the two years, but scholastic educational services picked us
up. And this was right when the mainstreaming act
was really coming into play. When, when I started
kindergarten, I was not allowed to go to the
local school. I had to go to a special
school, even though intellectually I'm no different than you
are. but the mainstreaming act took place in 1972.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And by first grade, I was then able to go to a local public
school. So, jump ahead seven or eight years,
which was when we were filming Feeling Free.
The, the thought was, we, we have to
expose the public to diversity so that students
can become comfortable when these other students are
suddenly sitting in the desk next to theirs.
>> Right!
>> So it was a really neat experience,
my other panelists, or, friends, I guess, would be the better word. we, we, we
did audition, and, so, they were able
to get some of really awesome articulate kids.
>> Mm-hm
>> One had cerebral palsy, one became blind
during the process of our show. And so
that was very interesting to befriend somebody that's,
I, when I first met her could see.
>> Mm-hm
>> And when we
finished, could not see at all.
>> And remind me again, how old were you at this time?
>> I was, ten. Ten to 12. Right in those crucial years, yeah.
>> So at, was this the same age where you
were noticing, I mean, how old were you when you,
sort of, noticed yourself that you were different from other
people. And maybe you, when your parents also noticed this.
>> That's a really good question. my
parents were given the diagnosis when I was
18 months old. And they wonder to this day
whether or not that was a delayed diagnosis that
no one had the heart to break it to them. now this was pre DNA testing, this was
all based on X-rays, and femur length. Femur is
what they really go for in measuring the femur
length. and there we were sitting in Boston, one
of the top medical communities in the country and
the gentleman that gave my parents the, diagnosis
was T Barry Brazefin, who was sort of the
Dr. Spock, not the Sci Fi doctor Spock but
the sort of, the pediatric voice of America in
the 70s. And so I love to tell people that I was diagnosed by that man, myself.
So they knew when I was 18 months old.
I think many little people like myself did not
come to their own realization until they're in school.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because that's when the teasing really starts.
>> Sure.
>> And the accessibility, if you will. Especially back then.
You know we're talking about the 70's. There wasn't any
Americans with Disability Act. So that's when I was having
to struggle to, to access what my fellow students were accessing.
>> Did you notice so,
what kind of, experience did you have with
other students? Was it entirely negative from the
beginning? I mean, did, were people, you know,
were kids mean, were they, did they tease a
lot, did they, you know, did the just
sort of look unsure, you know, seeing something different
from themselves, what kind of interaction was it,
and did it change as you went through schooling?
>> luckily, I grew up in a very educated community.
You know, 30 minutes away from MIT, Harvard, you know,
all of the Ivy Leagues in Boston. and I think
that's, that speaks a lot to,
kids and their val, you don't have value system but their manners and so forth.
>> Sure.
>> So I don't remember getting teased too much. I'm sure I did and how
much of that I have sort of put under the surface.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And forgotten about. but I, I don't it, I have a tougher time even today
when I'm in an inner-city environment where my, the people surrounding me, don't
have the same etiquette. And don't have
the same education, the same exposure. And that's
really where I struggle more than where I grew up. In a suburb of Boston.
>> Well,to get a bit more of that sort of educated thought and idea I
want you to tell us you know, as a medical condition of dwarfism
what is, what do you know is the cause of shorter stature? And in
particular in your case, what is the, what is the cause of, of this?
>> Well, remember there are over 200 different types
of dwarfism, achondroplasia being the most common. So if
you were to meet another little person in your life,
most likely they would have achondroplasia. So I can only
really speak to achondroplasia. it is a dominant gene, it
is also a mutation. So, what that means is, an
individual can have achondroplasia for two reasons. One would be
their parents have it, and it's been inherited as it
was with my children. The other would be, it's a
genetic mutation, which is a complete Unexplained event, which is
what it was for me. I, I'm the only little person in my family. My little
brother is six three and my parents, my
grandfather was a genologist so you can image
he spent a lot of time looking into this. and I am the only dwarf in my family
of origin. But I then went on to meet my husband who also has achodroplasia.
>> Okay
>> We got married and we
have three children. I gave birth to two of them and I flew to Moscow for the
third one. To adopt from an orphanage. who also
has achondroplasia but clearly not from me or my
husband, she, from all we know, which is
really not much, is a mutation as well, her
parents were average height and I suspect in Russia,
it's a lot harder to be a little person.
>> Sure
>> Yeah
>> Are you familiar with the gene that
is actually mutated in most cases of achondroplasia?
>> The FR. The FGFR3 gene.
>> That's it. That's what I am.
>> okay.
>> There's a reason I don't teach science. I'm, I'm an
English and drama teacher and Spanish teacher not a science teacher. So
yes, very familiar. I, I don't spend a whole lot of
time conversing about it. what is really, really cool is that when
the gene was discovered. In 1994. In 1992, the National Convention was in
San Francisco. I was eight months pregnant. We had both my in-laws there as well
as my parents, and when we have a National Convention that Little People of
America puts on. A gaggle of healthcare
providers fly in, that have specialized or have
an interest in, dwarfism. And so, they'll be no less
than 15 or 20 geneticists from around the country. Sometimes we
even have international geneticists. And we all volunteered ourselves for
blood draw, when I was eight months pregnant. And they sent me
home with a vial for umbilical blo, blood that I was,
when I was going to give birth a month later
so that they could get umbilical cord blood. So, I
like to say we had a little bit of something
to do with the discovery of the gene two years later.
>> Absolutely.
>> Now, on that note I have two children that I gave birth to. One in
August of 1992, the other in November of 1997. The gene was discovered in
1994 or 5. So that meant that my pregnancies were very, very different. In 1992,
the only diagnostic tool that they could use
was ultrasound. And again, they were looking at
the femur in the fetus And they could not measure that accurately until I was 24
weeks pregnant. So at that time, they told me, and I was actually being seen
by the gentleman that wrote the growth charts for fetuses at UCSF,
and he was the one reading my film, my, my measurements, from the ultrasound.
And he said, Jenny, this is a tough one. He said, that femur
is in the seventh percentile. And typically, if we're looking at a heterozygote.
>> Mm hm.
>> Meaning that the embryo fetus has gotten the gene
from one of you. That femur is going to be
over the tenth percentile. Right around, between the tenth
and the twentieth or thirtieth, or something. and you're
coming in at the seventh, and that makes us very
concerned, that perhaps you are carrying a homozygote. And
a homozygote, what that means in, in lay term
is a double dominant. And in achondroplasia, they have
found that to be lethal. The baby is born and
lives no more than a week. Typically more
a matter of hours. Without life support. So
it was a really tough call. So, we went ahead and, and, went with what we
thought was right, and Alex was born, and
obviously he's still with us. He's 20 years
old, so he must be a heterozygote. Although he has had a lot of medical issues.
>> True.
>> jump ahead five years
later, and in between that, by the way,
I'd flew to Moscow to adopt the second child.
I'm pregnant again with our now 15 year old,
and I have an amniocentesis at ten weeks. And
within a week, I get a phone call
from a genetic counsellor at Baylor University in Texas
telling me, you have a heterozygote. 100% certainty. So
you can imagine the difference in the stress involved
around both pregnancies.
>> So do you think it's a, in your mind, knowing
in advance, is a good thing. You want to know even
aside from your case. Cause there's also a possibility that if
you're two heterozygotes have children that neither that a child gets. But.
>> Does not get the gene.
>> So what that means in lay terms is I could have had you.
You could have been my child!
>> Exactly.
>> I would have been 15, but nonetheless. So there is as much
of a possibility that I would have what we would call an average sized
child or even an above average sized child. I have friends that are
my size, very good friends. Whose only child, a son, is six foot four.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, I had as big of a chance of that as
I had of a lethal situation. Both of those being 25% chance.
And then I had a 50% chance of having the hetrozygote where
the kid gets the gene from either me or my, or my husband.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's what we wound up with.
We did never, we never experienced the, homozygote, thankfully.
>> Thankfully, yeah.
>> Although I have many friends that have.
>> What, so now I'd like to, just maybe talk a bit more about that, because
that seems like it could be a challenge.
Just, I guess first, in your mind then knowing.
Having this information. Being able to know this information up front, right, at
the beginning of your pregnancy early on. Is that something that's important to
you in the process? Was that something you were happy to know about
or do you wish you kind of couldn't find out maybe until later?
>> I'm going to skirt that a little bit and I'm going to
talk about it in third person because it's such a personal choice.
>> Sure. I'm going to tell you that I
have friends that fall into all of these different categories.
I have one friend that buried three babies in
five years because they kept coming up with that
25% chance. I have one friend who has two
average sized children. So they came up with that
25, the other 25% twice. and I have friends
that have said, oh, we'll never get pregnant. Because
we don't want a dwarf child. We went through
so much ourselves. We would never want that for our,
a child. I have friends that say, I'm scared
to death of having an average-sized child, which I
don't understand because I teach high school. You know,
that is not a big deal. And I have these
great friends in L.A. whose son, as I just
told you, is six foot four. so, you know, this,
this choice that we are now given, or the
access to this technology, maybe is, is very, very powerful.
I'm going to tell you a quick story. We, we had a regional conference in Los
Angeles about a year ago. Three women, all in their twenties, all kind
of grew up together, by default, I mean not necessarily in the same town,
but because they've been Little People of
America members all of their lives. All pregnant.
Now, they all have had the testing. One of them did not want to have
the testing, for religious reasons. But, far
along into the pregnancy, decided. I don't want to
go through baby showers. I don't want to
decorate a nursery, unless. There's a reason to.
So, it's not going to change anything about
the pregnancy, I'm going to go through the pregnancy,
but I need to know. And so she knew
she was carrying a double dominant. And there she was,
with a smile on her face, with the other two
women, one of whom had already buried a double dominant,
and was on her second try. And knew that
that one, I believe was going to be average size. And
then the third young woman, knew that she was having
a heterozygote dwarf and there they were all happy and
talking, and I just, the strength that the girl had that knew she had
a double domet inside of her, was just amazing. It gets a little bit more
sad. So, the baby lived a few hours, they waited the three months that they were
told to wait, They got pregnant again. And again, had the double dominant. And,
and kept it. And that's their own choice, and
aren't we lucky, in this country, that we have choices.
>> Right. how much, I mean, I can't imagine, you know,
the, the strength and the sort of, the, having to go through
a situation like that personally. how much of the strength going through
the actual reproductive process, you know, the, the joys and the pains
of giving birth and, and the specifically in this
case you know, being able to have access to
this information and knowledge. When you do find out
information if it's not the information you want, how
much of that strength is derived from you personally
versus a community maybe of, of other people. of,
of other little people talking to the other people
about this how, how is a community itself either
helped or hurt in any way?
>> Well again I can't speak from personal experience.
you know I, this, this again, this technology is bittersweet. It really is. I
can say that, belonging to a support
group like Little People of America offers a
tremendous amount of support. And we all know these statistics. We've been told
these statistics since. I knew what my odds were when I was ten years old. And
babysitting. And knew that I wanted to have
children. And I wanted to be a teacher. I.
Did that influence my selection of mate? Did
I say to myself, oh I better not find,
I better not fall in love with another
achrondroplastic, because we have a 25% chance of having
a homozygote? Absolutely not. Do I ache for my
boys, who will most likely, by mere fact of,
numbers will wind up with achondroplastic woman? And this will be on
the table. Do I ache for them? Before they are even you know,
really dating? Absolutely, I ache for them. That this is a
reality in their life and so the support from the community is there.
Now, again,
if, the one thing I've learned over the years is just
because we're all little, does not mean we have the same politics.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Does not mean we have the same religious convictions. And so
I actually have found myself in a very awkward position. One of
the reasons I'm sort of skirting away from. my position on this
is that one too many times I have stated my position on this
to another little person, who is just as educated about this as I am
about this as I am and they have gotten up off of the conversation and
walked away. And so, the support is
there. But, the naysayers, or the conviction, the convicted people are
also there. So it's, it's, it's a very very delicate discussion.
>> Sure.
When, when was your first introduction to this
community of, of other little people? did you find
that when you were still growing up as a
kid? Or is this more of something you were,
became, became more active in as an adult? I
suspect, that my parents came home after being delivered
the diagnosis by Brazelton, who probably gave them, not
the website, because there were no websites. But the
phone number of the local Little People of America,
which I will now from here on out call LPA
contact. And I suspect that by the time my
parents got home, because there were no cell phones back
then, they called the local contact and said, when
is your next get together? So, I have known, nothing
else but LPA. I was raised in LPA. And
the analogy that I use with new parents I'm often
put in touch with, because I, I have sort
of a, little bit of a handle in, in the
medical community here in the bay area, both at
Stafford, at UCSF, and at the children's hospital Oakland, everybody
has my phone number. So I'm often, my husband
and I are often put in the position to be
that phone contact, or in this day of age, the
email contact. And so the advice I give those people,
that originally, you know, the first Talk is typically
over the phone, or on the computer. It's not face
to face. Is I try to really stress the importance
of joining LPA right then and there. Because it's more
for the parents, at that point, than it is
for the kid. And the analogy that I use, is,
you know? We've all been on airplanes where the flight
attendant does her, his or her spiel. And they say.
Parents in event of emergency put the oxygen on yourself
first and then assist your children. It's exactly the same
thing in any sort of support group as far as
I'm concerned. Those parents need to get to, educated, they
need to get their head wrapped around this, so that
when the kid does off to school at five years
old, and comes home in tears, because they couldn't reach
something. Because they were teased. because they couldn't reach the cafeteria
line, whatever. Those parents are ready to go. They've been told in advance
that those are the questions that kids are going to have. They have contacts of
other parents whose kids are a couple years older. And, it just doesn't,
that's just the way it should be done. And, and often times, I'll be honest,
we have had very eye opening conversations with 40 somethings that were not
encouraged by their families To come to LPA. And they have now found us on their
own. And here they come. And often, with drink in hand at the dinnertime dance,
they're, they've got their head in their
hands, saying, what did I miss? Where have
I been? And you know who they're mad at?
>> Their parents.
>> So, Ginny, I just want to know a little bit more about you. Why don't
you Just tell me where you're from and I want to know what, what you do for fun.
>> I grew up in a suburb of Boston called Lincoln,
Massachusetts. we had, we, we, were on the train line and
I don't remember which line but I could. I was going
into Boston on my own when I was 12 years old.
>> Oh wow.
>> I
don't know if my parents would have allowed that in
this day of age but, so lots and lots of
fun. Great place to live. And then I moved to
Colorado. My father was transferred just as I was starting high
school. And that was a little bit unfortunate. It was
two weeks before high school started, and we were uprooted. it
was the best decision for my father but maybe not
for me so much, because, you know. it, it's hard for
a little person to break into a new situation. Especially right in the middle
of hi, at the beginning of high
school. but anyways, stayed in Colorado Springs. for
all for years, and then got out of Dodge. Colorado Springs and my politics do
not align well. So decided to come west to the bay area for college.
and I've been here ever since. And, I believe that was about 25 years ago.
>> Nice.
>> As far as hobbies, I kind of try to get into whatever my teenage
and above children are into. So that we can maybe spend some time together.
[LAUGH]
and I'm not And, I'm first in what it is
that they're talking about. So, that's in every, ever evolving process.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> and no matter how hard I try I, I don't seem to be up to snuff enough. But
I, I by default I have to know how
to sew, I do sew. economically these days it doesn't
make sense to sew your clothes, it's cheaper to
buy them. But by default I have to alter clothes.
So I, I am in front of my sewing machine
at least twice a month, altering pant, pant length and
sleeve length.
>> So, what is that...I've never thought about that before, but
I mean, where, where do you shop? I mean, do you,
are you, I mean, do you have to shop in different
areas or places for things than most people? I'm a good old
size eight, like 60% of women out there. And so I'm
buying the same stuff your mom's buying. I'm bringing it home and
cutting it off at the knee and probably tapering it a
bit, 'because I don't want it this wide what it. You know
at the knee it would be this wide so I'm tapering
it. And I'm altering it, the same thing on the sleeves
>>
>> Because our torsos are not affected. As
you can see, you and I are pretty much.
>> Right.
>> Sitting
>> Yeah.
>> At the same height.
>> That's really interesting. and what kinds of
hobbies do your kids get you into besides,
>> they usually involve technology or soccer, so I'm,
I'm slowly learning the ropes on, social media. Soccer,
I'm just really struggling with it. I sort
of complain that there's a fraternity in my house
and I'm the outsider. dinnertime conversations always come
to soccer and I kind of disappear and nobody notices.
>>
[LAUGH]
Well in sort of in line with a lot
of these everyday items, I'm, I'm really curious and
I'm sure other people are too. What are, are
there any advantages to having a slightly shorter stature in
general? this is a very common question. And I
always say to myself, I gotta write it down.
because I never, you know, am fully prepared. But
in this instance I, I did think about it some.
let's start with the disadvantages. Cause I it, that, that's a
shorter list. The grocery store It's horrible. And I haven't quite
figured out the best time to go. If I were not
little, the best time to go, clearly, would be 6:30 or 7:00
in the morning, when I'm awake because it's not crowded. But
it's a very bad time for me to go when it's
not crowded, because there aren't people in the aisles to turn
to and say, can you hand me that jar up there. So,
I think the compromise is more like 10
a.m. You know, which unfortunately because I don't
work full time, I can do that. And, I can always pretty much count on waiting no
more than two or three minutes for somebody
to show up in the aisle. I'm not going to
go to customer service every time I need
help. You get very savvy at flirting with people.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> To get what you need. So I
will strike up a conversation instantly, with the
main motivation being that I need that can
of tomatoes at the top of the counter.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> other disadvantages, it really depends, its hard
to go into communities that are less educated and less mannered. Because
we are so comfortable in, in our community, which, granted,
has gotten to know us. On so many different levels...
>> Mm-hm.
>> Over the last 20 years. My husband and
I, both our careers, myself as a substitute teacher and
he as a an IT guy for small
businesses in our immediate area, we're very well known.
>> Mm-hm.
>> only because people don't forget us, you know. It's not
a comment on our personality. However, I've, been told that we sort
of have magnanimous personalities as well. so we get really
comfortable in our environment. And then when we step out to a different
environment and the reaction is totally inappropriate, it's, it's,
it's a slap in the face. It's a reminder.
Can you, I mean if you're comfortable, can you
give us an example of a negative reaction that you.
>> I actually can have, I can give you two. And, and, and they're a little
bit different. one of them was pure ignorance.
There's nothing more upsetting to me than to be
in an environment where it's the adults. That are
grabbing the children and saying, look at the midget, come
here, come here Frankie, come look at the midget. I
can not believe that in this day of age that
still happening. But when I go into inner city environments,
in a grocery store, you know grocery stores are really
harsh places for me to be. Not only because of
the physical thing but you're trapped. You know, you're in
a grocery store line, and you can't go
anywhere, and you've got kids with their fingers
right, five feet away from you. And you're
trapped. So that is definitely, you know, hard. The
other example of ignorance was an educated ignorance,
if I dare say. The five of us
were on our bikes in San Francisco by
the Palace of Fine Arts. Like we're riding our
bikes around, and we rode in front of a tour bus
from, with tourists from another country, that their cultural
norm is to be curious, and to be scientific. And they
forget appropriate behavior in that quest for
curiosity! And so, we can pretty much assure that when we go by
a tour bus, of, or a group of tourists from other countries. Those video cameras
are trained on us like snipers. And my husband has gotten to
the point. He's a very very patient man. But he will walk up right
to the camera, and say you will delete that picture. He gets very upset.
>> I imagine.
>> And imagine having 50 of them on your family. You feel like there
are snipers on you.
>> What's the difference in your reaction to how other people
respond to you? Versus how people may respond to your children. Is, are, are
your feelings about this trait different for yourself versus how you see
other people react to it maybe your children or other relatives or friends?
>> I am the biggest mama bear you will
ever meet. You mess with my kids watch out.
>> Enough said. what
let's go back to some of the, some of, some of the advantages.
>> Oh yeah.
[LAUGH]
>>
>> Because that's a longer list. It really is. advantages, let's
see. Well here's a hybrid. Why don't we do the hybrid first.
>> Okay.
>> The spotlight is always on. Fair enough.
>> So you can be, entertaining. And the life
of the party. And everyone wants to talk to you.
>> You could could get a, a special spot on Tales from the Genome.
>> Yep.
but let's say I've had a bad day. The spotlight's still there. I
actually have a deeper appreciation for public figures. Because by default,
we have become public figures. I feel I,
I, can't imagine being somebody like Angelina Jolie
and Brad Pitt with their children. And talk
about being hunted. You know, and, and, not being able to go out for a meal.
Without, the intrusion. So, that's the negative side of that spotlight.
>> Well actually, and to go on a quick tangent, you
made me realize, you know, the way little people are portrayed in
the media, what aspect, I mean, what are your thoughts on
that? How, how are little people portrayed in your mind? Positive, negative,
in-between, mix, and how do, what is your reaction to that?
>> Our Sidney Poitier is Peter Dinklage. I am so proud
of him. And I want, along with hundreds of other little people, mostly female by
the way, want to meet him. For better, for worse, he's not involved
with our group, and I can't comment as to why. I would say
he's quite busy these days he is the top billed actor on
one of the most popular TV shows right now. He has been consistantly on the show
from, I believe, day one. they're not killing him off, like they kill
off everybody else. He, he will be king. I don't follow the show, but I
have enough friends who are thinking, you're crazy.
Why aren't you following the show? He's going to
be king. And, I would like to, my husband is not into the blood and gore and
sex to the degree that they are. But, I, I am keeping my eye on him. He
is our Sidney Poitier. And he is up for his second Emmy in two years. Right now.
>> So
he's really been sort of a, for you. a
big pivotal figure. And, and a good image of
being, like. Everybody else. And he's super popular. and
it's, it's, it's almost not even. I don't want to say,
not noticed as a trait. But it's, it's not
important in who he is, necessarily, as far as, it
happens to be part of him. And so that
gives visibility to the trait, but the focus on him
is not because of his stature.
>> Not in this particular
[INAUDIBLE]
show.
>> Right. Exactly.
>> he had sold himself to the devil a
couple a times. He's tried real hard in the interviews
that I've seen not to. I mean he has been
eating out of tuna fish cans for a, you know,
the beginning of his career. While offers of being
leprechauns and, and, Santa's elves and so much were being
thrown at him. He, he, really was keeping true to
himself. There are a couple of pieces of work that
I would prefer that he had not done. But
for the most part, he redeemed himself with Station
Agent, for which he got an Oscar and he, come to find out, he's been in a lot of
little stuff, I'm going home to watch, another tv
series he was in, seven episodes on, because I'm just
so curious. I think it's a shame that he
has not identified with our group, because he has so
much to offer. up and coming pep, students
that want to maybe delve into the film industry.
>> Well, outside of Peter Dinklage, as far
as media portrayal goes. Even you know, maybe
not in the Hollywood sense, just in news
or TV, what else have you noticed about portrayal?
>> in the last decade, there has been a lot of curiosity
with little people for a while. And I don't know if
I'm allowed to say this, We were nicknaming the TLC network
The Little Channel. Because they seemed heavily interested. At one point
there were five or six different series going on involving little people.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So now that we've, seem to have lost
our luster a bit. And we were one of them.
But only for two episodes. Only for two. And
we. We get very defensive. What we did was not
reality TV. We, we, we, we prefer to call it documentary
TV, is what we did for two episodes. So, I, I
think the word has finally gotten out what the correct terminology
is, but just in case, let me educate you on that.
terminology, as you may know, evolves in different groups. So in the
African American community, my mother, who was raised in the south in 30s and
40s was told to call that com, that population something. That I'm not even
comfortable speaking, but that's what they were called. And well they were
called Negros, not the other one, Negros. And you
know, I think when I came around to school
in the 70s, we were told no, the word
is black, and I've used the word black. And now
when I use the term black, I'm told, oh
no, it's African-American. But then it gets even more
confusing cause I have some African-American friends that say,
I wasn't born in Africa, I'm not African-American, I'm black.
So, there's a lot of confusion around that, and then not to mention what the
rap stars are doing with the terminology. So,
the terminology. When, when Little People of America
was first formed in 1957, the name
was actually Midgets of America. It was primarily
a venue for entertain, entertainers. and they kind
of made light of the union, for lack
of a better word. Well then slowly, educated,
serious people started joining the group. And one
of the first tasks I had, was to get rid of the word midget. Now what's
wrong with the word midget, for me and many others, it conjures up the image of
vaudeville, when they were called midget performers. And
they would go around, much like a travelling circus.
And they would get on stage. And you would see, a little person
like myself, with a cigar hanging out of their mouth, and a diaper on.
>> Mm hm.
>> And making total fools of themselves. So when
I hear the word midget, that's what I conjure
up in my mind, as do, many in our
organizations. So I think the word is finally dying.
>> Mm-hm.
>> occasionally
it will be used, In hockey leagues, it's
still used up in Canada, a, a, signifying the
younger kids I think, and and I, I think
the little people group up there has been really
working on that. so the terminology that I'm
comfortable with, long-winded answer, is I'm comfortable with little
person and I'm comfortable with dwarf, because that's what
I was raised with. Now, that's not to say
that my children, and they're okay with that too, but
maybe my grandchildren will have come up with a new term.
>> Right. Actually, and, and I probably won't
include what I'm about to say, but you made
me think of it, and it's just so amazing
to make the connection that, y'know, I think in
the, as far as sexuality is concerned in the
gay community. I mean the evolution of those, of
the nomenclature of the name, and what people are
comfortable with and, in one way I'm fascinated with,
because it's a group identifier. And I honestly think people should,
y'know, we should respect groups enough to call them what they want
ot be called. You know, and I think in the gay community,
you know, there are people who live and die by the word
queer. you know, that's what they want to be called. They reclaimed
it. There are other people who identify as gay. There are other
people who identify, you know, you know I, I, in several different
ways. And the community argues about it all the time. You know,
internally you know, like, no we shouldn't use
this word, or we shouldn't use that word. And
then that can even be confusing for people in
the outside looking in cause then they're like well.
>> What do we do?
>> What do we do? so it, it's amazing to parallels there between.
>> That's that book that I want you to read.
>> Yeah, I'm definitely going to check that out.
>> So I have an adorable story to tell of my 15 year old who.
I need to remind myself is indeed a
really great kid because sometimes I, I forget that.
He was a, a coach this summer for
summer sports camp, he's very, very athletically minded and
unfortunately, do to being only four feet tall.
is not athletically bodied. Now, put him amongst other
little people and he's going to bring home the gold
medals. But, when the population is one in 20000,
that's just not going to happen on a daily, weekly, it happens on an
annual basis. So next week, we're going to the world games for little
people, and I suspect that my 15 year old will be setting records
in all of the different events that he is going to be doing.
>> So exciting.
>> So he, with my urging, took this job over the
summer where he was a coach in training with a third party
sports camp. And every day, I would say, okay,
you gotta give me one story, you know, based on
the day, tell me one little thing that happened.
And one of these days, he came home, he says,
well, something interesting happened today. So I stopped everything
I was doing, so I could listen. But you can't
ask too many questions, because then he closes up
again. He says, somebody asked what time it was, and
I pulled out my cell phone. And the kid said, what?
You have a cell phone? That's not fair. You're only eight.
And Ben said, no I'm about to be 16, and the kid
said, oh, that's right you're a midget. And Ben said,
[SOUND]
well actually Sammy, I'm, I'm not a midget. Midgets a
really mean word, I would rather you call me a dwarf.
Or a little person but you know what, Sammy? You met
me two days ago so you should be calling me Ben.
>> What a great answer.
>> And I said, Ben, was there an audience for that
discussion? He said nope, there was just me and Sammy. And
I said, Ben, some'ing tells me, that when they all went home,
Sammy got into the car and told his mother about the whole conversation. And Ben
said oh, mother, pfft. The next day, Sammy brought
Ben a card that was handwritten in cursive about how
great it was to have Ben as his coach, and that he would never use the M-word
ever again.
>> What is, what is driving a car like? I mean do you,
I mean, do you have any, like, do you have to have something?
>> What is driving your car like?
>> Well I know, but I'm asking like, foot pedals though. Like, is that?
>> I do.
>> Okay.
>> I have we have extension pedals.
>> Oh okay.
>> That bolt on to the
[INAUDIBLE]
that you use. There are steel bars With,
you know, C clamps and all that hardware
that I don't know what it's called. Takes
about 45 minutes to put them on. Not much
fun. takes about 10 minutes to take them off. So I could drive your car if I
brought my extra set of extension pedals and
I was totally limber and could fold myself up
[LAUGH]
into a small little ball and be upside-down with
my, hex wrenches and all that sort of stuff. And
if you wanted to drive my car, no problem, you
would just have to take them off, and I would
ask you very nicely to put them back on
when you were done. So, when I was going down
to Los Angeles to interview during college, with the you
know, the film industry, I rented a car in Burbank,
and I put them on myself in my business suit. And proceeded to get on the
five in Burbank, and about 300 yards between,
ahead of the intersection of the five and
the ten, my gas pedal falls off. And I have nowhere to go. Except for the
shoulder that really wasn't a shoulder. And I
had to drift, because there was no gas.
So there was not enough room on the shoulder to open the driver's door for
somebody to come help me. So, Eventually, a
Latino guy pulls over, and between
his limited English. My limited Spanish. He offered to help. But he had to get
into this rental car and drive it with me in it. And drive it off
of this freeway. In order to do it. So I was saying a few prayers at that
point, and everything was fine. He fixed it and
he followed me, he asked if he could follow
me to where I was going to make sure I got there. That was the last time I
ever put extension pedals on a rental car. Soon
after that, the, I don't know if it was
Reagan or Bush, But one of them did something
very nice, called the Americans with Disabilities Act. And
that means, now, that, as long as I give
my rental car company 24 hours notice, they have
to have a car waiting for me with hand controls. So I just did it today as a
matter of fact for my trip next week, and
doesn't cost me any extra. I get to walk
right off that airplane into my rental car just
like you do. I had to get comfortable with driving
with hand controls, and it's hard. legal or not,
I used to, still maybe do use my cell phone
a little bit when I'm driving. And you can't
do that with hand controls because one hand is always
on the steering wheel. And the other hand is
on the mechanism that acts as your gas and brake.
>> I want you to, if you can, list for me, if
you can, quickly, some advantages. Other
advantages. We sort of, we keep getting sidetracked
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Well, a spotlight was the hybrid. Okay? So
let's work up from the, the, the spotlight thing.
people remember me, that's kind of the spotlight, too.
But if I want to jog somebody's memory over
the phone. And I'll say, hey, this is Ginny
Foos, your little customer. Oh yes, how are you?
[LAUGH]
So I get the information quicker.
>> It's an identifier.
>> Yeah.
>> When I get tickets to a show. I'm kind of stretching it a little
bit because I just identified the fact that you and I are sitting about the
same height. But, if somebody like really tall sits in front of me, I can't
enjoy the show. If people stand up, like they do in a concert, forget it,
I can't see anything. So I explain this. Now what's interesting is,
is that, Ticketmaster, when they say
disabled seating, they're really thinking about wheelchairs.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because it's all about numbers. I mean the same thing with the Americans
with Disability Act. The, the architectural standards
that were set were for people in wheelchairs.
So if I were to stand up right now next to
you, you and I would be about the same height, but you've
got long arms that I don't. So ATM slides, gas
station slides, you know all of that is meant for you in the wheelchair.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> They're like three inches too tall for me. It's beginning to change a
bit. I'm having an easier time with the brand new gas pumps. I think
there's been enough yelling and screaming from the
dwarf population. And, and we've become more of an
advocacy group. Our current president is awesome and totally
into advocacy. So maybe his efforts are paying off.
>> Uh-huh.
>> But, so, so, long story short. I tend to ramble. the tickets,
I can say I need good tickets, and I get good tickets.
>> Right.
>> so that's an advantage. we went camping recently, and I was able to stand
up in my tent and change my clothes, whereas the average size friends could not.
>> Definitely encounter that problem before.
>> Yeah.
>>
Anything. What about airplanes?
>> Oh, yes. Airplane travel is, I would
argue, more comfortable for me but the difference
is is that my feet are dangling. Look at right now and yours are not. So
mine are going to maybe go to sleep, but when I've gone on a long flight,
if there happens to be an empty seat next to mine, I can actually lay down.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> The flight attendants don't like it much, but
I can. If, I would do the exact same thing!
okay. let's, I want to pivot and ask two,
we're going to try to wrap up here, and I'll
ask two different questions. I'm going to ask two different
kinds of questions. first, I'm going to go with is,
knowing everything you know now as yourself
and with the current technologies even maybe thinking
about the possible advances in technologies that
we'll have in the future. in your life
time or even possibly beyond that. Would
you change, would you choose to be different?
And, sort of variation of that, you know,
if you could choose this for your children.
how would you?
>> I think, like, my first answer is, we call it the magic
pill. You know, if you had been able to take a magic pill to not be a dwarf.
And I think my response to that magic
pill would have been different depending on what
decade of my life you were asking about.
I would most likely have taken that magic
pill in middle school and probably high school. Prior to that, I don't think I
really care, I was just a kid I've never faced outright discrimination in my job
[INAUDIBLE].
So I think that magic pill may have
been taken between middle and high school but after
that you kind of get awfully comfortable in
your skin. So. I often ask the question when
I'm teaching. And by the way, every time
I go into a new classroom as a substitute
teacher. I almost have to address this. What's
funny is when I'm, if I'm teaching, a primary
grade, up to, like, second grade. The conversation lasts about two minutes.
And then they all want to tell me about their dog, or something.
If I go into high school, it, they can milk it for
a good 45 minutes. And then I get into a little bit
of trouble. because I don't do what I'm s, there to do.
And I'm not quite sure if they're milking it because they would
prefer to talk about this and try to, you know, pull the
wool over my eyes, and not do the work that the teacher
has left for them, or if they're genuinely interested. I'd like to believe
it's, it's a combination of those two things. But the question I posed
to them is, do you think it's harder to be born disabled or
to become disabled later on in your life. And the people that are really
[UNKNOWN]
and thinking have actually, it blows my mind, when they give me the answer that
I am looking for which is this. Most
definitely it's harder to become disabled because something
has been taken away from you. With
the exception, perhaps, of being blind or deaf.
Because if you become blind later in life,
you know what things look like. So you
can reference that when you can no longer
see them. When, if you become deaf later
in life, you've learned how to talk. You can talk, and I just, I just want to
kiss them when they give that answer because
they truly are thinking about it. And so
when I think about our soldiers that come
home, disabled. I really feel for them. Especially soldiers
who were big, strong, buff guys and girls. And they no longer
are. And I, and I feel for them. And I'm so proud of them when they turn that
around and they become the wounded warriors.
Or the wheelchair rugby team or something that
they're putting that energy in, they're channeling
it into a different realm, a positive realm.
>>
so let's end with, with one question on, You
know for, for someone it's it sounds like you
know, being a little person can have its challenges,
probably like most traits, regardless of what the specific trait
is. Going through middle school can always be rough
and everybody's at different stages in their life. When,
if you could give a message to. You know,
young people in particular but anybody who feels different specifically.
It could be something so obvious like something like stature. It could
be something hidden. you know. What, what do you say to people who
have their own struggles. And particularly with your perspective. How, how would
you tell them to. To what's the best way to handle their struggle?
>> This is probably trademark, but it does get better.
It's a catchy phrase, but it's so true.
>> So, in general if, if you can
just get through middle school, and find some friends.
>> And high school.
>> And you live in a progressive area like the bay area. Because I think that
if you, if you live in a sheltered,
less educated, conservative area, you're going to meet more obstacles.
>> Great.
I think that does it for us right now. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> I appreciate it.